[inaudible].
Here's the question.
Everyone's been wondering for the past
few days,
what would happen if both North Korea
and South Korea merged in z one single
nation?
Yes,
I know this isn't something that's going
to happen in the near future,
but it certainly is a possibility and
one that might actually happen sooner
than we expect.
Just one year ago,
nobody would have predicted that.
Now in the spring of 2018 Kim Jong UN
would shake hands with the South Korean
President Moon Gin.
So what would a Korean reunification
look like?
The truth is that is historical
precedent and for all of this,
yes,
my day view is of course I'm talking
about German reunification.
As you may remember,
Germany,
he used to be divided into two separate
countries and eastern block with a
socialist communist regime and the
Western block with a capitalist system,
Berlin Wall came down and East Germany
was absorbed by Westerman and since then
the government has spent lots of money
so that the eastern Germans could enjoy
a similar lifestyle to the wealthier
western Germans.
Many experts consider this a success
story.
Some of them claimed that this could be
a model for what the integration of
North and South Korea might look like.
I mean,
think about it.
In both cases,
there's capitalism and socialism.
In both cases.
One side is Paul,
while the other side as wealthy,
and in both cases they share a common
language,
common history,
and to come in.
But now the question is,
what was the German reunification as
successful as it looks on paper?
Can we say East Germans today aren't
doing as well as their western Nader's?
Well,
the answer is no.
Even in soccer,
we can see small differences.
Since Germany was reunited,
there've been no eastern teams in the
Bundesliga since 2009 the western teams
still dominate the national sport.
In fact,
there is only one east German team in
the Buddhists Liga,
the rb Leipzig,
but it's just one team and a soccer
league of over 18 teams.
And the same applies in economics.
But where the differences turn more
scary is when we talk about politics.
For example,
in the last election,
the radical rightwing afd has ended the
parliament as the third largest party.
This radical anti immigrants and euro
skeptic party has gained the majority of
its vote from regions in the former East
Germany.
This is mark the first time since 1961
that a far right party that says this
kind of presence in German parliaments
and that's a view is actually pretty
frightening.
Benj of the east.
How anger in former GDR helped the afd.
So the real question here is this is the
process of reunification done.
What can we learn from Germany if it
could be applied to north and South
Korea?
Well,
today we aren't going to answer this
question,
but before we do,
let's take a look back at the history to
the victors go the spoils often or it's
unconditional surrender,
the allies divided and to for military
occupation zones,
Britain in the northwest,
France,
in the southwest,
the USA and the south and the Soviet
Union in the east.
There's a lot more we could say about
this time,
but we're not going to go into every
little detail because,
well,
if we did,
you'd be staring at my face for a couple
of hours.
Yeah.
But suffice it to say that from 1949
Germany was transformed into two
different countries.
West Germany officially known as the
Federal Republic of Germany with on as
its capital and East Germany whose
official name was the Democratic
Republic of Germany with its capital and
East Berlin.
East Germany was the communist region.
Well,
West Germany became the embodiment of
its capitalists.
Occupants.
While West Berlin started to look more
and more like a big city would in the
United States,
east Berlin became Moscow's carbon.
Yeah.
Top.
According to East Germany's first
constitution,
its citizens enjoyed certain basic
rights,
even the rights to strike,
but in reality it was a little freedom
or policy related matters were decided
by the Pellissippi Eric,
the executive committee of the Socialist
Unity Party.
That's the main and almost only source
of information in the country was
directly financed by the only party.
Here's a great example of just how
unbiased it was.
Sure.
The Central Oregon of the Socialist
Unity Party celebrating 100 years of the
communist manifesto.
East Germany's economy,
as you may have already guessed,
was it century plans and almost
completely owned by the state,
the central governments at the price of
housing,
basic goods and even services.
So basically every year the government
would publish a list with the mandatory
prices of every basic good.
You'd want to buy a bread roll,
five marks,
a thousand bucks for a Sony Walkman and
so on and so forth.
Even if you had the money,
there were waiting lists in place for
goods like cars and electronics.
I mean,
who really wants to wait 10 years to get
a travel card?
Take the unemployment generated by these
strips,
price control,
take all of those empty supermarkets,
take the scarcity of primary basic goods
and pair those with aliments like a low
birth rate and guess what?
You guys,
you got lots and lots of people who want
to escape.
Jen,
what did the government do about this?
Well,
they built a wall to stop people leaving
the country in order to justify this
movie.
The official state propaganda claims
that they were building the walls.
You protected their country from fascist
infiltration.
That the actual reason it was exactly,
yeah.
As you can imagine,
what would having a literal wall between
them,
the relationship between east and West
Germany wasn't exactly friendly.
In fact,
West Germany didn't even recognize the
East German government because they
claim to be the only legitimate state
for all Janice and to the east did the
same thing.
Now this might actually remind you of
something.
Yes.
It's more or less the relationship that
the two careers have with each other.
Although in the former case,
there were no nuclear bombs involved and
just like north and South Korea raw
reaching an agreement,
east and West Germany normalize their
relations in the 1970s but the real
twist in history that came in the year
1989 no one could have anticipated that
the 40th anniversary of the GDR would
also be,
it's lost and that Germany would be
reunited one small,
but then history if found a way to
surprise us all the speed at which these
changes occurred with astounding only 10
months after the fall of the wall east
and West Germany,
we'd become a single nation.
The new Germany has here,
secretary of state,
James A.
Baker,
the third set,
let her legacy be that after 45 years we
finally got the political arithmetic
right.
Two plus four adds up to one Germany in
a Europe whole and free bus make no
mistakes.
This was not a merger between two
countries.
This was a complete absorption.
Basically on October 3rd,
1990 East Germany disappeared as an
independent country and became a part of
West Germany as this was definitely a
good move,
but it did have some downsides
reunited at last.
It's like the two states where one once
more,
but not everything was exactly sunshine
and rainbows.
Huh?
Or West Germany was extremely wealthy
and has high productivity and was very
industrialized.
East Germany was the opposite.
The Soviet controlled state at a lower
productivity,
less wealth and eight totally different
political system.
Again,
this was a very similar starting point.
Does that have north and South Korea,
although less extreme,
but the process to be successful,
the two states needed to somehow find a
way to unify that two completely
different structures.
So now the question probably in your
mind as well,
what exactly did they do?
Well,
basically West Germany exported all of
their laws,
their taxes and their regulations to
east German.
In exchange,
they also took care of all the
infrastructure costs.
This means that the western taxpayers
would pay for the highways,
the railroads,
and the streets of eastern Germany.
And now I know what you're probably
thinking right now.
This sounds pretty fair,
right?
I mean,
if you want to join your poorer neighbor
to create a big country,
you kind of have to help them recover.
But economics is way more complicated
than just pouring money into something.
Basically,
the reunification meant the total
collapse of the whole eastern economy.
And why was this?
Well,
just think about it.
I mean,
having a single country means having a
single market to a single market where
Western companies where several times
more productive than that,
eastern counterparts,
so east in factories,
they just couldn't compete.
For example,
East Germany produced the famous travel
car.
I mean,
compared with a bmw or an Audi,
a trevor is just a toy.
So the demand for those cars,
well it just dropped by for day.
Yeah.
Many refugees hoping to settle in the
West,
dump their communists,
built vehicles near the West Germany
embassy in Prague.
Alright,
so imagine the situation you work in a
factory to the company.
It has to close because nobody's buying
their cars.
Then you go to the supermarket and
everything you wanted to buy is produced
in the West because well they have the
best factories.
But then again,
everything is more and more expensive
because well surprise,
all of a sudden you live in a rich
country with really high crisis.
This isn't the end of the story here.
I mean imagine you're an old man in the
east and you get a pension that's
calculated based on the prices during
communist times,
but that was 1999 you go to the
[inaudible] and the bread has a western
price,
which is terrific.
Cool.
You can probably see where I'm going
with this young people,
I mean at least they could emigrate and
believe me they did,
but what could the elderly do?
And just hold on a second now because on
top of all that we have the currency
exchanges.
Do you see the two countries,
they're different currencies with
different values.
So how did they make it work while the
finance ministers of eastern and western
Jimmy,
they met in a room and they decided on a
fixed exchange rate between the West
German mark and the East German market.
The public demanded a one to one
exchange and on July the first 1990 the
banks in the former eastern Germany
provided people with the unbelievable
exchange rate of one to one.
I say this isn't quite marks because the
theory was one thing and the reality was
quite another.
Most of the banks would sell you one
western mark for two eastern ones.
This is an exchange rate of two to one
and on the black market,
that exchange rate would be anywhere
from eight to one to 12 to one.
So from one day to the next,
all the money that you had in your
savings,
we'd lose half of its value.
So when I,
you might be wondering,
well,
what did the German government do to
manage the situation?
Well,
the answer is subsidies,
subsidies,
and our whole palm or subsidies,
west German taxpayers paid medical
bills,
infrastructure,
and they were doing everything they
could to prevent eastern Germans from
migrating.
We're talking about almost 70 billion US
dollars every single year since 1990
that is the equivalent of organizing for
Olympic Games.
Every single,
yeah.
Sorry.
Now I know what you're wondering off to
almost 30 years.
Is this reunification process done?
Can we say that Germany is now an equal
country?
Well,
the viewer,
the answer is yes and also no,
but not mixed.
According to one study,
a good share of German state that they
wouldn't marry somebody from the other
Germany,
three quarters of the German population
thing.
There are still different mentalities
between the east and the West and 10% of
east Germans have never once traveled to
the other side,
and of course there still differences
in economic terms.
If you look at this chart,
you can see that at the time of
reunification,
the GDP per capita in the east was 9,400
euros as compares to 22,000
euros in the West.
Today it's 27,000
euros and 41,000
years.
Yes,
the differences are more subtle,
but nobody can seriously claim that
there are no differences and of course
we still have the cultural differences.
A research study done by Jacob
University in Bremen measured community
spirit is considering a number of
factors including trust in institutions
and tolerance towards the Lgbtq
community as well as ethnic minorities.
All the regions,
the ones made up east Germany appeared
in the bottom half of the index
and finally we have the political
differences that we can see in the
latest elections.
Eastern Germans voted for afd of far
right wing party and d Linka of far left
wing party while western Germans chose
more moderate candidates.
This divide in the polls shows house.
Still to this day,
eastern Germans are heavily influenced
by Russian politics.
This is important because one day
eastern Germans could hijack German
politics and destroy that sense of gem
in moderation.
Now going back to the case of North
Korea,
imagine what would happen if North
Koreans kept voting for communist
parties.
I mean all of a sudden you have a leader
like Kim Jong and making decisions that
also affect South Koreans,
which sounds pretty scary.
Now of course there are many bright
sides do the German reunification,
and as we've mentioned in many of our
videos here at visual politic,
Germany is still a model for other
countries.
But as we always say,
not everything is perfect and if there
has to be a Korean reunification,
one day it will not come without.
Yeah.
Risks.
But
now it's your turn.
Do you think the eastern Germans could
radicalize the political debates in
Germany?
Do you still feel the German
reunification could be a model for the
Korean Peninsula?
Please leave your answer in the comment
section below.
And of course,
don't forget to visit our friends from
the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this video
that we're not mine.
And if you like this video,
we publish brand new ones every week.
So hit that subscribe button and you
won't miss a single post.
And as always,
I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast see you there.